oh hell yeah like Filipino food I know
nothing about Filipino food I'm Filipino
I'm not a great Filipino don't speak
Tagalog I remember I was in the Filipino
Street food taste test any food that's
in the shape of a ball probably Filipino
they're balls or balls they're balls I
like the color
whoa that has a weird smell you know
what corn ball I feel like it's a know
these are Filipino they're also really
good Philippine yes I'm saying
Philippine yes based on the ball theory
I'm just gonna say right off the bat I
think this is Filipino it looks like a
banana that was stepped on and scraped
off the bottom of a shoe put some banana
ketchup on this it might be Filipino not
Filipinos got to be somewhere in South
America
don't really want to eat it I want that
chicken put my Yoda food
it's very gingery I might be making that
up no I feel really stupid you were so
confident dang it
this looked like a spring roll that just
smells like yard work I'm gonna say it
is full of you know because I like it
I've liked everything that's Filipino as
well so I'm gonna change it to Filipino
instincts look it's so red yeah yeah
there's a lot of peppers not Filipino
are you sure you know what you made me
doubt myself tandoori chicken that's
Filipino good something new I like that
what this looks like a delicious pastry
this looks like right how moist cake
looks in a commercial for most of what
we've eaten that is Filipino it has eggs
in it so I'm gonna say that this is
Filipino I can't believe I got them all
right girl all right don't they'll be
able must love me even more now if I had
this I wouldn't need a boyfriend don't
hate a boy I still don't know what
Filipino food is you got your sweet
cheese you got your barbecue guys good
job in the Philippines bring somewhere
that over here I'm surprised how many of
them we got right I'm not I'm great at
this I killed it I knew which ones were
Filipino
you're welcome Philippines yeah they
were all good what's it is a Filipino
food is good